why would a communist an officially
atheist nation create a new religion
well that's what the Chinese government
is doing by creating a Christian
theology that will better fit with its
national condition since 1949 China's
Christian population has surged from 1
million to more than 67 million and it's
slated to be the world's most Christian
nation in the next 15 years the
government probably sees this as a major
threat especially since it is torn down
crosses on hundreds of churches this
year China's Constitution does guarantee
religious freedom if you practice one of
the five state sanctioned religions but
that guarantee hasn't helped Christians
much so far